all right guys
bang bang lunch money time while while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina marinova
pompliano or p-i-m-p as some of you like
to call her
pam what's up what are you going to play
uh soccer you think you're messy
i've been criticized that i don't speak
loudly enough
so or enough into the microphone no
because it smells bad
you you talking this i talk in that
microphone every day but it's disgusting
because you can't smell it um
who is the sponsor today anthony
today is sponsored by block five block
five's got three products they've got a
crypto exchange where you can buy and
sell
crypto currencies they've got a product
where you can deposit crypto and take
out a us dollar loan
against your collateral or they have my
favorite product which is an interest
bearing account
that interest bearing account allows you
to earn up to 8.6
apy absolute no-brainer you can't find
those interest
bearing account rates anywhere else
anywhere
anywhere so go check it out go to
blockfy.com
lunchmoneyblockby.com lunch money
let's get into it let's get right into
rumble
also i have a comment for the commenter
who said that
me you not being able to hear me on the
mic yesterday was a feature not a bug
i'm on to you i i see you i saw you
responding to people all right what's up
with the
first topic tick tock skirted a privacy
safeguard in google's android operating
system to collect unique identifiers
from millions of mobile advices devices
data that allows the app to track users
online without
allowing them to opt out and this is a
tactic that's been banned by google
so one of the secrets to the internet
years ago was if you got the mac address
and they see a mac address uh you
basically could track
the user everywhere they went on the
internet um and it was used for
advertising purposes it was like amazing
and then people were like wait a second
i think we're violating the privacy of
these users
we should probably chill out and stop
allowing people to
track mac addresses uh they literally
banned it so google and others have
banned the use of this
um if you're doing that they will not
put you on their uh app stores and
things like that
uh but tick tock was doing it and they
were doing it
by hiding it inside a second layer of
encryption
that people couldn't see uh on first
glance but then tick tock responded and
said
the current version of tick tock does
not collect mac addresses
operating word being current version
yeah i mean look these are nefarious you
know
frankly [ __ ] things uh and this is
why you're gonna get banned from the
united states
literally because you're doing nefarious
things you're tracking american users
and you're owned by a chinese company so
hey if you don't want to do that stuff
sell or
get out of the united states and on top
of that i think that people have got to
understand
it's not some like political nonsense
the the
it is very clear if you look at the
source code it is very clear that they
are collecting incredible amounts of
data more data than american tech
companies
and a lot of that data is very sensitive
and so it's just a promise of if you
have the information
why should we let you have it what are
you doing with it you could say oh we're
not doing anything with it then why do
you need it
we look really good today do you think
it's because we didn't turn on the
lights people can't really see us
come on what's the next step let's go
okay um i'm in a rush today
yeah i got things to do so let me take
my time to do
calls we hurt russia's feelings
yesterday
russia has rejected the notion that
its uh vaccine is not safe and um is
not safe and unproven um it's claiming
that
there is a speaking of the microphone
it's claiming that there is major
information warfare against its vaccine
um you know uh russia said tuesday that
its vaccine had been approved by its
health regulators
making you're the worst
no just speaking to the microphone so
yeah well i can't read and speak
oh you i see i already read the internet
i can just tell you vladimir putin's
upset about the vaccine it's not
vladimir it's
his minister of health no vladimir putin
is upset too and he keeps insisting that
it's safe and effective and you know my
question is
why didn't you take the vaccine his
daughter did again he claims why didn't
he take it though
that's a good question vladimir yeah why
don't you take it dude
if you're so uh sure that it's safe go
on national television and have them
shoot you with the vaccine let us all
watch what happens
with the vaccine why not i don't really
like this little
we got it well we have we have to use it
we have to do this because you're
unwilling to speak into your microphone
so we we're going to get this fixed but
until now
polynomial is going to keep doing this
hitting her with the microphone
all right what's next she could be mad
at me that's fine but she's going over
to talking to the microphone
no come on what's next so there's this
blockchain startup alchemy which powers
70
of the applications to ethereum and now
uh i don't know it's stepping on the
spotlight but i thought it was
interesting that it's backed by jay-z
did you know jay-z is investing in
blockchain of course he is everyone is
but look again this just goes back to
the idea it's like a bunch of people
duncan niederrauer charles schwab john
hennessey
jay-z jerry yang right will smith all
these people
uh basically what they're doing is
they're trying to remove the complexity
from building blockchain applications so
that the overall industry can grow
uh it's a developer tool um you're not
speaking into the microphone no i am
trust me
there's nobody that ever complains that
they can't hear me i got a loud
booming voice how's business booming
don't worry you see and then i get the
echo in the room too
i never cannot be here our neighbors are
gonna complain that's fine
tell them to uh leave us a note on the
door uh
so look at at the end of the day people
wanna make money where are you gonna
make money
on infrastructure and tools uh in a
innovative space
that's exactly what these guys are doing
they claim that they count four million
users uh worldwide so let's see what
happens
good for you i just think it's
interesting that jay-z's and investing
in
blockchain i may actually i've been
thinking about something crazy
i may go on a year-long journey and
learn to code
see the fact that she just laughed means
i should do it what are you gonna
just document the whole the whole
process i once learned or
no i once tried to learn to code in
college and then on a
saturday evening my professor came in
and he saw me crying on my computer
because i i didn't know how to code but
i had to code
i was like what is this this is stupid
stupid
i'm gonna ask no questions about that
stuff wait listen
um wait what listen listen
um very suspect story go ahead why i had
my project was due come on i got things
to do let's have a second
um uh oh guys
if you watch no no okay okay
i was gonna make i was gonna make you do
your impression of uh
selling sunsets uh what's the name
romaine
oh i can do it yeah if you guys watched
it there's a new netflix show uh
called uh selling sunset it's on what
episode it's a docu-soap
i don't know what that means i just
clicked on it one day because i thought
it was going to show us cool houses on
the internet and like go and like
you know like go through the houses i
like looking at them and then next thing
i know i'm watching like a soap opera
these girls are all yelling and
screaming at each other
and one of them has a husband who is a
french model and his name is romaine
and he does a great impression he's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ]
the girl she says is [ __ ] no it's
[ __ ] you're not going to come to my
wedding is [ __ ]
i don't know i find that so funny
because literally it's exactly how it
talks
all right what's up with dion dion
sanders
mr prime time himself do you think dion
sanders
absolutely um what sport did he play
nfl uh that's not a sport that's a
league football football what other
sport did he play baseball
facts do you know that he actually
played
in a football and baseball game in the
same day major league baseball ended in
the nfl is that allowed
yeah he was the first person to ever do
it if i was a professional sports player
i'd play
um dodgeball that's not a professional
sport
if it was okay but it's not okay so do
you definitely not athletic enough to do
that now
you literally just got
so dion um is leaving the nfl network is
he a commentator
yeah he first of all he's a hall of fame
football player who now has been for the
last four years
with the nfl network and he's known for
uh his nickname is prime time and so a
lot of people don't know this
he showed up to the nfl draft when he
was a kid
coming out of college he showed up the
nfl draft didn't stretch
had on his street shoes supposedly laced
up his street shoes
ran the 40-yard dash ran like a 4-3 or
something and then just left
i like him so he's also wearing bandana
and gold chains on the field
and when he would get interceptions he
would do a high step where he would
basically taunt the other team
he just was the best how is that allowed
back in back in the day you could do a
lot of stuff you can't do but you could
hurt the other
team he didn't care so they couldn't
catch him they can't touch him dion is
prime time
he was the man still is so dionne is
headed to
bar stool sports of all places but you
got to tell the context so
he's been locked in this contract
negotiation with the nfl network for a
while
uh they can't agree on what he's worth
he obviously thinks he's worth way more
than they do
uh so he basically walked yesterday he's
just like i'm out like this is dumb i'm
not gonna
sit here and keep negotiating with you
guys uh so he bounced
and when he bounced uh barstool sports
dave portnoy erica nardini they pounced
immediately signed him uh and now he's
going to bring his show
from nfl network he's just gonna do it
on barstool he's gonna have a podcast
uh this is gonna be absolute chaos the
fact that dion sanders is now partnering
up with big cat
and uh dave portnoy and kfc and all
these folks
football season is going to be
absolutely interesting yeah
yeah but is there even going to be
football when all these players are like
i ain't playing because the koben
yeah the nfl says they're still playing
college football it cancelled two
conferences canceled yesterday
fall and they said they're going to play
in the spring but the nfl continues to
say they're going to play so we'll see
what happens
oh so yes okay well that's interesting
you can't have the fall without football
right i'll go crazy yeah he'll go crazy
all right what's next when we first met
he was like i'm not even that into
watching football and then he was like
psych
i got catfished um i i lasted two
saturdays i didn't watch a single game i
was like i don't even care about that
stuff
and then third saturday i was like ow
i have to watch all the games all right
all right what's up excuse me what did i
tell you last night who's the star
who's the star oh claims that uh uh as
i'm trying to figure out the audio
issues with joe
you guys haven't met joe yet but joe
cloak is helps us out with all the audio
stuff that's great
uh i told planet i was like look we're
gonna figure it out we just gotta get
the microphones the room's a little
uh echoey all this kind of stuff she
goes i'm the star
i don't deal with those little minion
things just figure it out and let me
know when it's
fixed i didn't say it like that
okay so airbnb is close to filing to go
public
in a move that would underscore a
surprising rebound for the home sharing
giant in the ipo market but it's unclear
if there it's unclear if they're going
to stick to their
planned um timeline to go public in 2020
because of covet so we'll see
air bnb will be public
okay at some point who cares when
who cares how much only people
who have investments in airbnb you do
you do not have investments in airbnb
yes we do what how did i not know about
that
did i know that let's go did i know that
i told you
let's go let's go but anyway so
that's good come on brian get into
speaking of airbnb guys this is great
there is only one blockbuster store left
in in it is in bend oregon
and you it's allowing it's allowing
three small groups to each spend a
different night inside hey
watching time out i can't you can't you
can't look over here
and not talk in the microphone it's easy
oh i just read all that stuff hey
there's a blockbuster story there's one
left since the 90s
and you can go sleep over there guess
what i didn't even read the article
i literally just told you what the
headline said and i don't have to look
at it it's amazing what happens when you
have
short-term memory but it's powered by
airbnb and you can go
airbnb and the blockbuster and watch a
marathon of your favorite movies
who would ever want to sleep in a
blockbuster
oh i would love if you wouldn't slept at
blockbuster i'd get a day to myself
you're never getting a day to yourself
all right what else you got for us
anything else no i just have jokes
anybody
in for a joke some guy says that he's
that he's gonna leave because your jokes
suck
there's another guy who said i'm gonna
leave if these bad jokes continue well
guess what
they are continuing come on hurry up
okay i have one
no you don't yes i do okay
what do you call blueberries playing the
guitar
did you see that the blueberries playing
the guitar yeah
i don't know a jam session
come on come on it's a good one what do
you call
a dog magician labra kadubro
a labradabra could do though
guys that's gonna be it for lunch money
today please
stick with us we're gonna figure out
this audio issue like i said i have
another
microphone right here you see this
nonsense i have this
we're trying to figure it out because
we've been using a piece of software and
it doesn't allow
both microphones to go at the same time
which is ridiculous you don't have to
explain your
issues yes i do i'm airing out my issues
because the star doesn't want to deal
with these minion issues but i'm working
hard
i'm being tedious i'm being diligent to
try to help you guys be able to hear
so who doesn't want to talk about but
that's it for less money today all right
while wall street's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right
see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends